[Music]
[Music]
it is the mother
when we go in
we offer our prayers and respect
[Music]
our lifestyle is on the ganges
our food comes from it we bathe in it
and we drink the water from the river
[Music]
during the day i do the work of a
fisherman
sometimes we go in the day
sometimes we go out to fish in the night
we catch fish to sell it
and from that we are able to eat and
survive
we are poor people
fishing is our livelihood
[Music]
before we had these nets we used to make
nets by hand
and we used handmade tools to fish
but when we started getting the plastic
nets in the market we stopped making our
own
[Music]
our handmade nets we simply couldn't
catch as much fish
we would only catch like
four or five pounds
and then it takes a long time to make it
by
hand but when you buy it from the market
you can get the net ready in two or
three days
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
now with the plastic nets available in
the market
we can come back with 100 or 200 pounds
of fish
[Music]
plastic nets last for a shorter amount
of time maximum
five or six months when they are worn
out we sometimes use the nets to make
fences or ropes
otherwise we burn them or throw them
away
[Music]
[Music]
why would we keep the damaged nets
we throw them out in the river when we
go out
we leave a lot of them out there
i don't know what else we can do with
them
this river means everything to us we
consider it our mother
[Music]
but we also have to fish every day for
our survival
if we didn't do this work
where would we get our food
[Music]
you